so it goes on
to manage the area
then we have the
and stock solid Laska variant
ok now it will of course also be
interesting
white plays here but quite ambitious
ok and he was one prepare
well I'll take
something with f6 maybe
then e5
at least four active
party  on ag 6 but
what I have that is so dangerous
doesn't really seem like the
jumper is in a good position
what's not happening anymore
yes but now I have 5
interesting
well why so I don't
think I'll have other problems here with that  on
the king wars
so maybe we'll see
something to do on the
line ourselves
open that
thing well the
50 maybe that's dangerous
I'm a bit slow then on
the line
that makes me do it to me anyway like
yes
maybe the whole thing  asking a bit
sometimes say on 5
yes i have seen it here too
now do b5 the idea with the idea
for
25 a little bit of time g  I gained a
bit of time at least
I think there has to be a cover
somehow
there doesn't have to be a cover
so what if I play now
yes
I have I'm here come on I'll do it
here a little trick on the side with it
now. de 4  with the idea of ​​the three yes very
good
yes I think he doesn’t
want to allow the three but taking it is stupid too
yes well I understand that of course it was
n’t that long either
but anyway what if I
take
it now then in touring then when I  it springs
play
everything very difficult
so yes i wanted to do the three but he
maybe the
three
yes i don't know i want i want
to come here as soon as possible what you live on
c3 or so the four or something
like that first in chess
ciao
but me  had there been a mobile because
behind with
so
now 2 what's next
for the 7
the 6
check
I'm so
what was so ridiculously broken and a
totally lost because he's here in my god
man oh man oh man